all right well the golden knights did it
again in case you haven't heard vegas
clinch their second round series at home
by winning four straight games now the
focus turns to montreal and the stanley
cup
semifinals john treach joins us live in
studio with more
with the vegas general manager hey john
that's right when vegas journal manager
kelly mccrimmon was a kid in the great
white north the montreal canadiens were
his country's
most sacred institution now he leads a
team
deep in the american desert trying to
crush canada's last hockey hope
and he knows the secret weapon is the
electric home environment
t-mobile arena is not for the hockey
purist it's part playoff passion park
pool party
and 100 invested the golden knights
changed the course of the series in game
three when they came from behind to win
and then
win again in game four in last night's
game six well the two teams traded goals
but
colorado was cold clocked by the energy
and grit of the golden knights and their
ambiently awesome fan base
it was powerful even for a hockey lifer
like mccrimmon
just unbelievable it really is and it's
uh it's not just the the volume but it's
the it's the vibe and the energy
that you that you feel i think that both
our series against minnesota our series
against uh
colorado they made a difference they
they contributed to our
team winning the game and you know let's
be honest down two nothing coming back
to
coming back to vegas for game three if
you don't win game three
probably that hill's too steep to to
then climb against a team that good
the startling sounds of game day could
impact montreal even more because of
the 14 day canadian quarantine laws
there will be no traveling fans from
canada
at t-mobile arena the canadians may pump
computer-generated noise into their own
arena but
the flurry chance raining down on them
will hit differently